Pour trouver la tombe de Yul Brynner, il y a
d'abord tout une prairie à traverser. Au fond,
un petit cimetière orthodoxe : le propriétaire
des lieux nous sert de guide. D'abord l'icône
orthodoxe, puisque le cimetière à
l'origine orthodoxe. La tombe de l'acteur,
l'acteur qui est russe à l'origine, puisqu'il
est né à Vladivostok. Une tombe très modeste,
dans un cimetière lui aussi modeste. Comment
imaginer qu'en dessous reposent les cendres
d'une star du cinéma hollywoodien mondialement
connue ? Un lieu qui attire son lot de visiteurs.
J'ai deux types de visiteurs : certains qui
viennent pour l'abbaye, certains qui viennent
pour Yul Brynner. J'ai différentes personnes
qui le voir : d'abord les Américains bien sûr,
qui sont intéressés par le personnage, les russes
également puisqu'il est d'origine russe. Vous avez
aussi toute une clientèle qui s'amuse à faire
les cimetières donc ça c'est un peu différent.
Et puis alors vous avez par exemple pas mal de
gens qui s'assimilent physiquement à Yul Brynner,
des gens qui sont chauves et notamment j'ai toute
une clientèle située au niveau des motards. Yul
Brynner, acteur bien connu des baby boomers.
L'homme au crâne rasé, star du cinéma des années
50-60 et 70, oscar du meilleur acteur en 1957 a
joué dans une quarantaine de films. Le voici en
1956 sublimé par le technicolor dans le péplum
"Les 10 commandements" ou en 1959 dans un film
français de Jean Cocteau "Le testament d'Orphée".
L'homme parle très bien le français comme de
nombreuses langues d'ailleurs. Après avoir émigré
de Russie puis de Chine, il s'installe avec sa
famille en France. Un pays qu'il ne quittera
jamais malgré sa carrière américaine. Il est
le propriétaire d'une villa en Normandie, il
est aussi le parrain de Nathalie Reims et de
Charlotte Gainsbourg. Fumeur invétéré il meurt
le 10 octobre 1985 d'un cancer des poumons. Mais
pourquoi Yul Brynner et il enterré en Touraine
alors qu'il n'y a jamais vécu ? L'explication se
trouve du côté de sa religion. Yul Brynner
était orthodoxe. Il est décédé à New York,
il a été incinéré et puis ses cendres ont été
rapatriées en Normandie. En Normandie parce
que son épouse vivait là (donc sa 4e épouse)
qui a décidé à un moment donné de revendre la
villa. Elle a décidé de transférer ses cendres
à paris, ça ne s'est pas fait et ça a dérivé sur
Luzé parce qu'à l'époque il y avait une communauté
orthodoxe qui occupaient les lieux. Or il se fait
que dans cette communauté il y avait un moine
qui connaissait directement la famille Brynner et
qui a proposé d'amener les cendre ici de Yul
Brynner. Demain les deux associations autour
de l'Abbaye de Bois-Aubry célébreront les
30 ans de la mort de l'acteur. Un dépôt de
gerbe est prévu le matin et toute la journée
le site sera ouvert pour les visites. Une
célébration modeste à l'image peut-être du
personnage. Dans les années 60 Yul Brynner
avouait à la télévision française regretter
l'époque où il était un simple citoyen anonyme